Your tone is your trademark.
It's not just what you say and how you
say it, it's the tone in which you
deliver it. My name is Matt Abrahams and
I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast, Talk Smart, the
podcast.
Today I look forward to speaking with
Jefferson Fisher. Jefferson is a Texas
board certified trial attorney and the
founder of the Fisher firm. Jefferson
teaches people how to navigate
high-stakes conversations by
prioritizing connection and clarity over
winning.
As a compliment to his New York Times
bestselling book The Next Conversation,
he's now releasing The Next Conversation
Workbook to further help people apply
his principles.
Well, welcome Jefferson. I am really
excited for this conversation. It's rare
that I get a chance to geek out with
somebody on all things communication.
So, thanks for being here.
Absolutely. Thanks for having me. I
mean, come on, a conversation about
conversations. Let's go.
>> So, shall we get started? Yeah, let's do
it. All right. So, you're a trial lawyer
by training, yet you've famously said
that we should stop trying to win
arguments.
What's the approach we should take
instead and and why?
As soon as you try to start winning
arguments,
you're losing.
People think that in litigation, in the
trial world, right? That's all you do is
win arguments, but that's really not
what you
you do. You only have so much limited
information to to go off of. And so, a
lot of the times what you're left with
is saying, okay, instead of trying to
win an argument, what can what can I do?
What I say is, arguments are not
something to win, they're something to
unravel. Meaning like just like a a
line, a piece of thread, or a water
hose, you you you you get knots in it,
you get kinks in it. And the better and
more efficient you get,
the faster you get at undoing,
identifying, and undoing that knot, the
better the conversations going to be.
So, instead of having to win, it's this
learn mentality of having something to
learn. So, I say
it it's rather than having something to
prove, have something to learn. So, it
has to do with the the overall approach,
right? Take this approach of learning
and it's not a competition, it's more
about connection and and really
understanding the other person's
perspective. Is that is that a fair way
to characterize it?
>> Yeah, who wants to be around the person
who always has to be right? The person
who always has to have the last word,
the person who
uh is is just the brick wall that can
never hear another person's opinion, who
wants to live in their own echo chamber.
It does not build anything. It only
decreases everything. The only thing
you've won with that kind of person is
is contempt. You've you've won
resentment. You've won awkward silence.
There's nothing good that comes from
winning an argument.
>> So, how best does one approach a
conversation to learn? Is it inquiry
through questions? Is it storytelling?
How how can we actually
execute on that idea?
Yeah, you you ask more
and talk less.
A lot of the times it's it's using
clarifying questions,
to be able to probe and to get somebody
else to share their perspective. It's
setting the standard at not winning,
not setting the standard at changing
their mind. It's setting the standard to
understanding their perspective. That's
where you start.
And there's a big distinction between
understanding and agreeing, right? Um
we we listen for understanding and that
allows us to then begin to foster that
communication to perhaps move towards
agreement.
I I particularly like asking open
questions. Help me understand why what's
going on for you there. Do you have
specific questions you'd like to lean
into to help with that understanding?
Depends on the context. If I can tell
them in a
um
a conversation that seems to be getting
friction,
and I can tell that the other person is
starting to get frustrated,
and things are starting to get bogged
down,
I'll usually ask, what's coming up for
you? What's coming up for you?
Right. It's a way of
making sure that I'm communicating in
that that moment that I can tell
something else is bubbling up
underneath, that something is happening
deeper than what's I'm hearing on the
surface.
And I've always got it answered. I've
always got an answer back from it. It's
far better than what's wrong with you.
But if I say, what's coming up for you?
That that's indicating, hey, I can see
something rising within you that that's
causing friction here, so won't we why
don't we talk about it? But the key here
is
not to use questions that begin with
why.
Whenever it's why, it's a lot more
accusatory. Is that something that you
found is true?
Absolutely, yeah.
Why questions can really put somebody on
the spot. And I like your idea of what's
bubbling up for you.
It it strikes me that what you're doing
in those moments though is you're really
observing not only the communication,
but how it's being said. So, a lot of us
struggle with taking that step back to
be monitoring the communication that's
going on while we're in the midst of
having the communication. You know,
those of us who study this call talk
about meta awareness, the awareness of
our communication as we're having it.
Are there certain cues and clues that
you look for? Is it faster speaking,
more emotional language? What are some
of the things that you're looking for to
show that there's some tension building
up, some friction? I pay attention to
pace
a lot.
How fast are they pushing the
conversation?
Faster they push it, the more they
typically want it over with. You know,
if I can pause,
have that kind of say, what's coming up
for you? What am I missing? How's that
hitting you? These open-ended questions
that
breathe space,
because sometimes that's that's what I'm
most trying to pick up on,
is the what's the rhythm of the
conversation? That's what I'm I'm
looking for. And that that tends to tell
me
if the person I'm talking to is
are we in the pocket together? Are we
connected? Are we connecting? Um or we
on different frequencies, like a if
they're on FM and I'm still on AM, and
we're not, you know, there's no way
we're going to be able to reach each
other. I really [snorts] like the idea
of pace, because you're talking about it
I think at two different levels. There's
there's the pace at which somebody is
speaking, speaking quickly. But then
there's the pace of pushing the content
forward. There there's a as you said, a
rhythm to com to communication and
conversation. And you can feel when
somebody's really trying to drive and
push it forward. And both levels, both
types of pace, I think are insightful to
to see if the person is agitated,
concerned, if there's friction building
up. So, you need to be cognizant and
focusing on that as well as just being
engaged in the communication itself.
You know, I've I've read that you have a
mantra you like to say, observe, don't
absorb.
Many of our listeners um
have a tendency when especially when
constructive feedback is sent their way
to to really feel it, to to to take it
on and perhaps get defensive. What
advice and guidance do you have to help
us really be present and observe without
absorbing something and perhaps reacting
too soon or too negatively?
What I mean is,
you get to watch a conversation happen
without absorbing all of it and deciding
that well, what they say is just who I
am.
So, if you were to have the mindset of
there is something for me here if I'm
willing to listen,
then things tend to go better. I know
that when you get feedback from
somebody, you know, they they say, don't
take criticism from somebody you
wouldn't take advice from.
Um it's
it's a it's a balance between hearing
what they say and knowing, are they
meaning it for your good,
or ultimately, you know, for your peril?
Are are they wanting to actually trying
to build you up? Is it something that
you just feel sensitive about? Did they
hit something on a nerve?
Or you actually interested in trying to
build on with it?
So, it's it's all contextual.
I really like everything you said, but
the thing that really stood out to me
was there's something to learn here, and
when you look for the learning, uh
especially if it's coming from a source
you respect, uh it can be very helpful.
And and that can help uh
take away perhaps some of the initial
defensiveness that one feels. And
approaching it from a place of gratitude
and expressing your your gratitude and
saying thanks can really help with some
of that. I want to move to a different
topic. Often our meetings and
conversations can go off the rails. They
don't go the way we expected. You have a
framework you call one frame, one issue.
How can we set appropriate
conversational frames at the beginning
or even before we begin the the
conversation, so that we can manage this
and keep it on track in a way that we
want, so we don't have scope creep or
anxiety that comes from that? I cannot
stand
meetings where you you get in, they go,
okay, everybody, we have a lot to cover
today.
You never get out of it feeling like you
covered really anything, you know,
because it was just too you're too
spread thin rather than going deep on a
few issues. It's applying that same kind
of idea. Uh where you talk about
everything, you talk about nothing at
the same time. So, what does a frame do?
Like a picture, it enhances what's in
it.
If I can put a frame around the
conversation, it does two things. One,
it enhances the conversation. It
highlights it. It makes it very clear.
Second, what it does is it gets rid of
all the anxiety
of the stuff that you might think we're
going to be talking about. So, if I text
you
and I say, "We need to talk."
Yeah, nobody gets that text and goes,
"Oh, high five. Yes, I can't wait." It's
always terrible that that feeling. Why?
Because you have that all that anxiety
about what are we going to talk about?
Well, you can remove that anxiety by
using a frame. And I really have it in
three three steps. Is one, that I tell
somebody what I want to talk about.
Give them the gift haha of telling them
what you want to talk about. Don't make
them have to ask. Tell them what you
want to talk about, the topic, the
subject, whatever it is. Number two,
tell them
how you want the conversation to end.
What's what's the checkered flag? Where
are you going? What do you want to What
I like to use is what I want to take
away from. What do I want to walk away
from
the conversation.
And then three, I get their buy-in into
it. That's as simple as, "Sound good?
Does that work? Can we do that?" Cuz
once you get that little nod of, "Yeah,
I'll talk to you about that."
It's it's like an implicit contract.
They they
they now are bought in to what I
committed
to talking to this about you. Now they
know I don't talk about anything else.
There's no other collateral issues. But
yet, you have a straight path, A to B. I
know exactly what we're going to talk
about. I know when it's when we've
checked the box.
And three, I've I'm built into it. So,
it's a way
of removing the difficult from difficult
conversations. And now it's just
talking. It sets expectations,
certainly. And it sets your vision of
what success looks like, and that can be
helpful.
It does require that your conversation
partner or partners go along with it and
have the same ability to focus you as
you do.
I I I want to flip to to talking about
digital communication. You, like me,
have a digital presence in your
communication. And you And you
distinguish between transmission and
connection.
I think many people today, especially in
the world of social media and digital
communication, confuse sending a message
with actually communicating
a message.
How does transmission fail us? And how
can we create or increase the the
connective nature of our communication,
especially in a world where most of our
communication is intermediated by some
technology?
Technology has allowed us to communicate
with people all over the world. People
you and I would never have ever come in
contact with our entire life.
And so, it's
it is pivotal and it's crucial to still
have that technology. What I would want
to see
is the ability to increase the mediums.
So, if it's something that somebody
really matters to you, it's not just
communicating digitally on a text or an
email,
it's to see them in person. It's to make
a phone call. It's to write a letter.
Like
diversify
your communication mediums.
It provides a different touchpoint in a
way that's
not going to be like
anything anybody else can do that's
unique to you. My handwriting's
different than your handwriting, but yet
you can see my personality in the
handwriting. Same as yours.
And I I I know that if you want to
increase what's good about digital
communication, is using it to aid and
support rather than using it to detract.
So,
the the take-home message there is, if
it's significant and important, reach
out. I like your notion of diversify
your channels of communication. I think
there's a lot of pressure to to be
efficient, and that efficiency gets in
the way. Your tone is your trademark. I
think that's a very powerful statement
that you make.
And I agree.
Many of us, though, are unaware of the
tone of our messages. We are so fixated
on what we're saying, and are we saying
it appropriately, and and did I use the
right words?
How can you audit your tone to be aware
of how you're coming across?
Well, you could say from the practical
side, you record it. And you listen to
it.
You get comfortable with hearing it.
Many of us are not used to that, and
we'll hear our voice for the first time,
and we'll be like, "Is that how I really
sound?" So, you could practically record
it, and you try to improve it as you
want. You could take coaching.
So, you need to have ways you want to do
that.
I
like to apply my tone to
or compare it to music.
So,
you think about
like what band
would match your style of communication?
There are times like, if I want you to
listen to me and to slow down, and if I
want to make you uncomfortable, I'm not
going to blast
AC/DC,
or I'm not going to blast Eminem. Like
I'm not going to do that if I want you
to be comfortable
and lower your shoulders. What I'm going
to put on some easy listening. I'm going
to put on some singer-songwriter James
Taylor type stuff. All right? And so,
it's that's the kind of tone
of like, am I giving you a voice? So,
it's it's trying to find
what
song does your voice give? Because if I
want you to be calm, I'm going to talk a
little bit calmer. That's the tone is
your trademark. If you're somebody who's
brash and angry and mad all the time,
that's that's who you're going to
become. Your your tone controls
everything. And there's plenty of times,
you know, it's not your words, it's your
tone.
Like, how many times have you probably
heard
from
I like from your mom or somebody, you
go, "You know, I don't I don't like your
tone. I don't like the way you said
that." Right. That that's what ends up
controlling the day. So, yeah, tone is
absolutely your trademark. I I really do
like that saying. And And tone again,
I think is a there there two levels
here. There's there's finding your
authentic natural tone that's that's who
you are.
And that's where coaching and recording
can help you.
But you also were talking about using
tone strategically to help you reinforce
your message. So, if we're having a
really serious conversation, I need to
reflect on what tone do I want to bring
to this conversation or have this
conversation have? And are there ways I
can leverage tone to really reinforce
what I'm saying? And And I do think at
both levels it's really important. It's
a It's using tone as a tool is a very
creative and strategic way to help you,
and I appreciate that.
Congratulations on your new workbook. I
I love the idea of a workbook. People
who know my work know that I'm all about
practical, tactical advice and guidance,
and a workbook's a great way to bring
that about. Uh in your new workbook, you
have lots of assessments. Your initial
assessment has you asking readers if
they struggle with stopping myself from
protecting other people's feelings.
Uh why do you believe we have this
instinct? And why is this the first
self-assessment in your book? I can
imagine other things could have come
first.
As a society,
uh and it's normal. We're afraid to
disappoint other people.
You know, we're we're afraid of their
reactions. So, what do you turn to? You
turn to people-pleasing.
And you And you turn to
making sure that you're always last, and
you give and you give and you you say,
"I'm not
worth anything unless you think I'm
worth anything."
And we tie our identity
to
how much we serve is how much we can be
okay with ourselves.
And so, that's why I wanted to start
with it. Is, "Hey, let's take a hard
look. Let's have a cold shower for a
second. Are
Are you
so focused and so afraid
to disappoint somebody that you'd be
willing to
lower
the way you see yourself, even just a
little bit? Is that okay with you?"
And I kind of have that that
self-reflective moment.
Because if if you want to improve how
you communicate,
that's a skill number one is you have to
learn to be okay disappointing some
people.
I like that you start with the internal
conversation first.
And I I think that's a really important
place for people to start. You know, if
you're working on your communication,
working on having better conversations,
start with that conversation you have
yourself.
And And look at your motivations. Are
they truly your motivations, or are
these societal pressures that you're
conforming to? So, I like that. I like
that. And I And I spent some time doing
the assessment myself. So, thank you.
Oh, thank you. In your workbook, you ask
readers to write an internal manual. Can
you share with us what this internal
manual is? I don't know that I'd want
other people having my internal manual,
but No, probably not. Talk Talk to me
about what it is and and how it can help
us identify sort of the rules and
procedures that that we leverage and
use.
I'd be willing to
bet that most people don't
really take an objective view about how
they communicate, how they choose to
communicate. They invest in a lot of
things. They
They know how they make their coffee.
They know what goes into X, Y, and Z,
but they don't know
how they communicate. So, the idea of a
manual is to write down what you allow
and what you don't allow.
Because if you don't, otherwise people
just have a remote control to you. They
have a remote control to your to your
emotions,
to your fears, and to your insecurities,
where they always know how to what push
your buttons. But a manual
says, "No, no. Hey, if if you and I if
you want to communicate with me, this
this is how we're going to do it." So,
instead of this idea
like a remote control
would say, "You can't talk to me that
way."
A manual has this idea of like, "Hey,
look, if you turn to page 74, paragraph
D, you'll see I I don't respond to that
volume."
I don't I don't respond to that tone.
That's below my standard of respect.
It's It's this idea of do you have
written out for yourself
how I will
be communicated, how I'll be talked to,
and how I'm going to communicate.
Do you have it? Do you have any idea at
all? And maybe it's okay to like write
it out, and yeah, it's hard cuz life
happens, and maybe you don't follow it
all the time, and there's exceptions and
whatnot, but you need to have some kind
of rough idea of what you will choose to
have allowed, be permitted, who has
access
to you in a way that can communicate
that matters.
I like this idea of reflecting on your
communication and thinking about what's
acceptable and unacceptable. I think in
my manual I'd have to have uh several
appendices because different contexts
require different operating procedures,
but I do like the idea of
self-reflection, and using the analogy
of a manual makes a lot of sense.
So, before we end, I like to ask three
questions of everybody I interview. One
I create just for you, and two are
similar for everybody. You up for that?
Yeah, let's do it. All right. So, like
me, you host a podcast, you write books,
you deliver keynote speeches.
All of this allows us privilege uh to
interacting with lots of amazing people.
Uh what's one lesson you've learned from
these different situations, your
podcast, your writing, your keynoting
that's changed the way you communicate,
something you've learned? We're all
still figuring it out. Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> And I find that no matter who I'm
talking to or where I am,
it's easy to think that they got it all
figured out. And once you really start
to scratch beneath the surface,
they don't really know what they're
doing either.
And so, you just have to
you have to fail enough
to kind of create a pattern of what kind
of works.
And that's what you go with. That's what
I've learned.
Yeah, no, I think that's right. I think
uh we we make this assumption that
everybody else has got this figured out,
and we don't. And in fact, we're all
we're all figuring it out together.
I appreciate you sharing. Uh question
number two, who is a communicator that
you admire, and why? I have a friend
whom you probably know, uh Chris Voss.
Yep. And the reason I admire him
is because we're kind of like
we did a um a thing on stage once, and
somebody said afterwards, "Y'all kind of
like fire and ice." Like, I'm
I'm the more softer side.
And Chris is not, you know, he he is
let's get the deal done and negotiation
and
and that balances me. And so, I always
appreciate
that he'll say something, I go, "Yeah, I
think that makes I make that makes a lot
of sense." But in terms of kind of
always walking away with something
practical
that is something that challenges me,
I'd probably say Chris.
Chris is a great guy. We've had him on
the show. He's cool. And both of you
provide really practical, tactical
advice and ways of getting into and out
of communicative situations that I
appreciate. So, thank you.
Final question, what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe?
One,
regulation.
You have to be able to say things with
control. And you do that not by
controlling the other person. You do
that by controlling yourself.
Two
would be
discernment.
Being able to
know what is true and to speak what is
true.
To be assertive, to say things with
confidence.
And
number three
would be setting direction.
Having a a goal.
Setting your intention of the
destination.
And to create connection
with the other person. So, when you're
able to say it with control,
say it with confidence, and say it to
connect,
I think that's a a pretty good recipe
for a good conversation. I agree.
Regulation, discernment, direction.
>> [snorts]
>> Absolutely key ingredients. All
predicated on what we've talked a lot
about, which is self-reflection,
understanding yourself, being able to
determine where you're coming from
before you try to engage others.
Jefferson, I knew this would be a really
great conversation. I knew we'd have an
opportunity to really engage in ideas. I
appreciate your your input, your
insights. Thank you for the time, and
congratulations on the new workbook.
Thank you so much. Thanks for having me.
It was great.
>> [music]